this better be it because I'm not eating
what's in my mouth right now
hi I'm Rachel and I'm Miss Asia I'm
Tyler and today we're doing the $100
$100 food fast food challenge underneath
one of those plates there is a hundred
dollar bill the rules are you will
choose a plate you will eat what's on
the plate and then only once the plate
is cleared can you check underneath the
plate first one to find it ends the game
and wins $100 I'm extremely competitive
it's disgusting I am here for every
dollar in that $100 bill I don't know if
I've ever had an Egg McMuffin the egg
McMuffin and I go back all the way to
high school also the last time I had
eggs was like 15 years ago
I haven't eaten eggs in months I want to
say that my max is like three but also
I'm totally like gonna make sure I win
if I get to that point because I'm just
gonna be mad that I ate three McMuffins
if I go past three I would be as
surprised as all of you guys I need to
care about the money I just want to win
before we share a song over yeah yeah if
I listen to be easier why did no one
come hi I'm prepped like a champion I
should have prepped like a college
student three two one go
how many bites does it take to finish
one bite finish you got it this is the
way that's gonna have it lift it this
way three two one go I've been earlier
that I'm keeping in my head as a big the
other way whoa wait so you guys heard
that differently I don't even know where
you don't that's a lie but you do now in
general I only color the plate is that's
as far as I do
do you have to find white as a color
because he said I know what color the
plate is there's a white plate I don't
think you would've called really
resented that vividly oh no I don't know
if I could do more than that all right
let's see it it's it this is it
I got a swallow now guys see you're not
even just here about $100 now you just
like like not feel sex but I want to see
her plate first and then I'm gonna damn
it are you serious I'm gonna smash the
next plate this is the one oh this is
the one I know I know that this is the
one breathing exercises open up
all right This Is It this is the one
ready if it's not this plate I'm tapping
out just know I'm gonna move slow what
if what if can I do it hold on oh my god
if we all tap out can we do look that
money if you all tap out none of you get
anything done I need you to wrap this
okay boy it's gone or something it's it
this is it this is it all right let's
see that plate tie this is worse than a
hangover food just came up with that
last birth all right I'm about to get it
for real you got it this is the one is
that three
this is the one this was the one that
was written we just got a hundred
dollars I have a hundred bucks you have
a hundred dollars this plate hundred
dollars what are you doing I don't
you're gonna see me no we're not even
gonna put that out into the world
oh it's a dub I don't thought that there
is literally no way I'm doing another
one I'm gonna be pissed cuz I'm not
eating this is actually a trick isn't it
there's no hundred dollar bill now do
they forgot to put the hundred gun I'm
gonna spin six hours I finished my
second ones ready yep if you do it we
all win
flip it good are you serious
where we at right now where we help it
looks like a is not gonna eat anymore
made to a plate I don't know I don't
know maybe right now I might don't look
at it no this cannot be real okay like
I'm like in Twilight Zone and I think
she just cried into the egg mcmuffin I
don't to do anything else you'd done it
better be come on money please you got
please thanks yeah
yeah I'm angry I'm getting the feeling
that my tactic was way off I'm usually
not if it's only the two of us I'm like
I don't I can't promise you I'm gonna be
able to eat another one after those
Salah you're gonna stop with this one
plate if it isn't under that one I am in
there I'm ready
not a praying man but
okay and so we're here worth it this
better be it cuz I'm not I'm not eating
what's in my mouth right now wait what
if it's this oh are you done
everyone has quit it's over I want
everyone to pick a plate and bring it in
front of you to be clear this will not
win any money
three two one go you'll all reveal that
one three two one go
Oh what okay this is a carnival game I
should have just stuck with my side of
the table
all righty on go three two one go money
actually when I saw them all laid out on
the table I was like this isn't gonna be
that bad because the other thing is like
it's egg mcmuffins they're very common
people eat them all the time that's the
other thing that made me nervous it was
like oh this is really whoever finds it
like there's no rhyme or reason
so when Tyler said the thing about it
maybe being a pink play tonight a white
plate I kind of just ignored all of my
planning before we started Tyler trying
to get some information was like do you
know where the hundred dollar bill is
and I said I know what color the plate
is so my mind immediately shot back to
that age-old debate is white of color
I found the plate so I feel like I kind
of won no I did not win that money I did
beat my own goal I said three was like
my Tapout I got the four I won in that
sense so I'll walk out here with pride
this is probably the most unhappy I've
ever been I hope I never eat another
okay
[Music]